[Musique]
qui parmi vous a déjà eu la sensation de
tourner en rond dans une conversation
pas mal et par tourner en rond je veux
dire rester coincée en parlant de la
météo être bloqué sur des banalités ou
encore avoir du mal à briser la glace
paradoxalement la conversation c'est le
propre de l'homme
nous sommes le seul animal social
capable de tenir et d'entretenir des
conversations les animaux comme unique
mais il ne couvert ce pas et c'est là
toute la différence
la communication elle sert à faire
passer des informations
ça peut se faire à sens unique ou par
texto par exemple rendez vous demain 19h
devant l'opéra la conversation elle elle
permet d'échanger sur l'opéra sur le
livret sur le compositeur et par dessus
tout elle permet d'échanger sur les
émotions que l'opéra aura pu faire
naître chez vous par la conversation les
humains peuvent partager leurs opinions
peuvent nuancer leur propos affiner leur
vision du monde
la conversation c'est ce qui nous rend
humain par la conversation
les enfants apprennent réunis tous
ensemble dans une salle de classe et pas
encore isolées et tout seul derrière un
écran
la conversation en fait c'est une
superbe école de la vie par la
conversation le véritable échange les
humains les enseignants les parents
peuvent transmettre
quand on y pense c'est aussi par la
conversation qu'on se fait des amis
ou alors c'est aussi par la conversation
pour tombe amoureux le plus romantique
des coups de foudre ne survivra pas
longtemps une conversation désastreuse
quand on y pense également
c'est par la conversation qu'on trouve
un travail
on passe un entretien d'embauché qu'est
ce qu'un entretien sinon une
conversation normes et alors on connaît
les enjeux
ce qu'il faut dire ce qu'il ne faut pas
dire mais c'est une conversation et tous
les recruteurs vous diront à partir du
moment où un entretien se transforme
bascule en conversation c'est quasiment
gagné ça veut dire qu'on partage des
valeurs une vision du monde une envie
aussi de travailler ensemble
la plus belle définition de la
conversation
c'est l'historien culturel théodore
el-din qui nous la donne alors je le
cite la conversation c'est un échange
réciproque est partagée qui permet aux
êtres humains d'échangés de la confiance
de la sagesse du courage et de l'amitié
c'est un art qui doit être à prix
pratiqués et constamment enrichie sous
peine de devenir bête répétitif ça vous
parle le stade avant l'impression de
vous répéter parfois comme un robot dans
vos conversations
moi ce qui me plaît surtout dans cette
définition c'est le terme
art parce que oui la conversation
c'était un art au sens le plus vivant du
terme au sens artistique gouard ti zonal
et à ce titre il mérite d'être sans
cesse enrichie d'être sans cesse
travailler d'ailleurs l'art de la
conversation il devrait être enseignée à
l'école alors ça fait cinq ans que je
donne des cours de conversation à des
parisiens de 15 à 95 ans ça peut vous
paraître bizarre de donner des cours de
conversation
tant la matière elle est riche et à
d'émouvantes c'est tout aussi bizarre de
proposer un toc sur la conversation tout
seul en un monologue du haut de mon
estrade pour revenir à ces cours de
conversations ces cinq dernières années
j'ai appris plein de choses mais surtout
j'ai remarqué la difficulté qu'ont la
plupart d'entre nous à entrer en
conversation lors de ses cours les gens
se confier et prouver leurs difficultés
a brisé la glace à se lier à l'autre ou
à entretenir sur le long terme d
pitié ou des conversations c'est pas
toujours facile quand on y pense
à l'heure des nouveaux moyens de
communication de la prolifération des
réseaux sociaux
la plupart de nos contemporains se
plaignent du manque de fond de nos
conversations
ça paraît de plus en plus compliqué
aujourd'hui il paraît plus facile de
discuter avec sept amis expatriés en
australie à l'autre bout du globe que de
vraiment se lier à nos voisins de palier
au cours de ces enseignements également
j'ai appris énormément de choses et j'ai
appris une chose capitale sur la
conversation c'est qu'avant toute chose
la conversation c'est une posture et une
posture ça s'apprend dans aucun manuel
la plupart des gens pensent que la
conversation c'est ça se résume au fait
de parler dénoncé des mots les uns à la
suite des autres
mais la conversation c'est une ouverture
c'est une ouverture au monde c'est une
posture et à ce titre c'est un choix que
c'est une décision que vous prenez on
devait on devrait être beaucoup plus
exigeant sur la qualité de nos
conversations
si on parlait j'ai au petit nice qui
sait où les vents vous porterons ou le
voyage vous mènera au contraire si vous
embarquez dans une conversation avec des
valises un petit peu trop lourde
si vous êtes un peu trop chargé ma vous
risquez de ne jamais atteindre la terre
promise de la conversation
ou alors vous risquez de couler entre
temps ou alors de faire demi-tour
décourager davance par le voyage ce que
oui la conversation c'est un voyage qui
ramène plus la conversation c'est une
aventure
alors il faut larguer les amarres il
faut oser s'aventurer et quitter le
rivage un petit peu confortable mais qui
sait où la conversation la vraie elle
vous mènera à partir de là je voudrais
partager avec vous trois idées
essentielles sur la conversation
la première idée et c'est la plus
importante à mon sens
c'est l'écoutent la qualité de votre
conversation dépendent de la qualité de
votre écoute
oui il peut se dire bien des choses
parfois ont très très peu de mots en
ancien français on ne disait pas je
t'aime on disait je t'entends est ce que
vous entendez bien des gens que vous
aimez la deuxième idée c'est l'ouverture
on ne sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
dans une conversation
ni ce que cache cet inconnu avec l'air
renfrogné toutes les sources de
révélations potentiel chaque personne
c'est quelque chose que tu ignores quel
plus bel adage pour partir à la
rencontre de l'autre car on ne sait
jamais ce qui peut arriver
qui est ce que je vais rencontrer
aujourd'hui quelle conversation je vais
avoir
qu'est-ce que je lai à prendre pour moi
c'est le meilleur moteur pour me sortir
du lit tous les matins la troisième idée
elle est capital c'est l'envié parce que
oui il faut avoir l'envié aussi de se
donner en conversation dans un monde qui
va de plus en plus vite qui est plus en
plus bruyants prendre le temps de la
conversation
prendre le temps d'écouter et d'être
réellement écouté assez de plus en plus
rares et à ce titre c'est un véritable
cadeau que vous fait pour saisis lors de
vos prochaines conversations
alors dans ces trois ingrédients
l'écoutent l'ouverture et l'envi est-ce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous marquent
c'est que j'ai pas encore évoqué le fait
de parler
la plupart de nos contemporains pense
que conversé s'est parlé mais rien
d'étonnant à cela puisque avant tout la
conversation c'est une posture
j'aimerais vous partagez une autre idée
afin de transformer vos discussions les
plus banales en conversation dont vous
vous rappellerez pendant longtemps j'ai
été inspiré en cela par la poétesse
activistes et écrivaine américaine my
angelo qui a dit un jour les gens
oublieront ce que vous avez dit ils
oublieront ce que vous avez fait mais
ils n'oublieront jamais la manière dont
vous avez fait en sorte qu'ils se
quand avec vous ça vous arrive vous
parfois de préparer vos conversations de
vous poser la question qu'est ce qui va
en rester là plupart du temps on
s'attarde sur ce qu'on voudrait que les
gens pensent
après nous avoir rencontré ou sur ce que
les gens ferai après nous avoir
rencontré par exemple dans un rendez
vous amoureux
j'ai envie qu'on sache que je suis
curieuse disponibles sympathique
charmante dans un entretien d'embauché
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on sache que je
suis compétente dynamique motivé que
j'ai envie d'avoir ce job mais est-ce
qu'on se pose la question de savoir ce
que la personne va sentir après nous
avoir rencontré une fois la première
impression à chaud passé qu'est ce qui
va rester au final de nos conversations
c'est là tout le rôle des émotions
il m'arrive souvent de ne pas me
rappeler du nom de la personne que je
rencontre parfois même de ne pas me
rappeler à quoi elle ressemble encore
moins comment les tabliers
ça n'a aucun intérêt mais en revanche il
ya une chose que je n'oublierai pas
c'est l'étincelle qui a jailli de la
conversation c'est les émotions c'est
cet élan c'est cette envie peut-être
toutes ces choses qui vont faire que je
vais m'en souvenir pendant longtemps
alors pour tout ce qu'elle peut nous
apporter j'aime profondément la
conversation
celle qui nous embarque avec elle et qui
nous emmène peut être un petit peu plus
loin qui nous force à nous livrer fellow
un plus un interlocuteur n'est pas égale
à deux mais où il dégage quelque chose
d'autre une force une alchimie un élan
peut-être des projets de travail d'amour
d'amitié
on ne sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
dans une conversation quand on y pense à
un niveau peut-être un petit peu plus
macro est ce que ce monde entier ne
serait pas une conversation
ininterrompue aussi quand on y pense au
niveau d'un état
quentin et à part à la dérive en général
quel est le premier droit fondamental
qu'il bafoue c'est la liberté
d'expression c'est la liberté de
converser justement alors à l'heure des
réseaux sociaux en tout genre
des nouveaux moyens de communication on
a l'impression que tout le monde du
petit individu aux marques aux
entreprises aux états ou aux chefs
d'état on peut parler proclamé twitté
sans arrêt mais est ce que on peut se
poser la question est ce qu'on entend
encore vraiment est ce qu'on ferait pas
condamné à devenir les récepteurs muet
dans ce brouhaha qui cette conversation
mondiale à leurs cours de ces cinq
années à de school of life paris
rencontrer beaucoup de gens est souvent
une question qui revenait dans les
conversations et qui semble être commune
à beaucoup d'entre nous cette question
c'est comment à ma petite échelle
individuelle
je peux changer le monde comment je peux
faire la différence
comment je peux faire bouger les choses
alors à notre échelle il est inutile
d'attendre de se réveiller un jour et
d'être gandhi obama ou steve jobs c'est
souvent les noms qui reviennent dans ce
genre de conversation pour moi on peut
tout changer le monde une conversation à
la fois ou en tout cas tous changés sont
des peut-être le monde de l'autre en
donnant le la des conversations alors
peut-être qu'il faudrait oser davantage
peut-être qu'il faudrait oser briser la
glace oser poser deux meilleures
questions peut-être faudrait oser se
mouiller mouiller un peu sa chemise se
jeter à l'eau la conversation c'est
avant tout une question de courage
alors voilà je vais vous laisser avec
quelques petites idées pour peut-être
tout à l'heure initié deux meilleurs
conversation la question classique par
exemple
salut savin à laquelle on répond même
plus en france salut ça va oui toi ça va
oui ça va c'est plus vraiment une
question aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'en mettant un tout petit
peu de nuance un tout petit peu
d'intention on aurait des réponses
différentes par exemple
bonsoir stéphane comment vas-tu ce soir
de même à la question quoi de neuf mais
je vous propose de répondre ou de poser
une autre question qu'est ce qui
t'inspire en ce moment enfin la question
qui semble ennuyer tout le monde
aujourd'hui en france le fameux alors tu
fais quoi dans la vie
je vous propose d'essayer autre chose
peut-être la prochaine fois qu'on vous
la pause etc de répliquer est ce que tu
veux savoir ce que je fais pour gagner
ma vie
ou est ce que tu veux savoir ce qui ne
fait vraiment vibrer je parie vous aurez
des conversations totalement différente
alors voilà je vous souhaite de vous
embarquer pour ce genre de conversation
osée aller plus loin faire bouger
peut-être les lignes de votre monde et
celle de votre interlocuteur
on devrait vraiment être plus exigeant
avec nos conversations alors ne
sous-estimons jamais le pouvoir de la
conversation et je vous souhaite un bon
voyage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]